live now to reykjavik and speak to our
europe correspondents adam parsons adam
yeah good afternoon and welcome to the
language for stadium
in reykjavik and as you can see behind
me
from our vantage point outside the
stadium we can actually get a pretty
good view
of the pitch and in there you'll see
there are no fans
in the stadium just a a few people
because of covid restrictions but
outside
quite a few iceland fans looking in and
one
lonely england fan that is chad thomas
chad is with me now
right chad you are representing the
nation
how does it feel to be the only england
fan that we have seen in this city i
just summed it up lonely
but i'm happy to be here it's a great
view it's like been in sydney itself
and uh i just hope people can get
revenge for euro 2016 where
we humiliatingly got defeated by iceland
21 i think we're coming tonight
well that was a very very grim result
for english
football you're a very loyal fan chad
you've followed england
all over the world but even by your
standards this is dedication how did you
do it
uh well obviously that's the five days
quarantine on in my flat on my own
i had a few people give me some messages
of support to people like jason uh david
and alex i was like texting me like
saying yeah go on chad you can do it i
got through the five days and
it was great now we're here now and
hopefully the team will be out in one
minute and can see his win tonight yes
you're up against you know quite a few
icelandic fans around us who
have come to watch the game is it going
to be a bit awkward if england
either win or lose how are you going to
react if you lose it'll be very awkward
because i'll be surrounded but i think
for win i mean i mean they've all
evolving great yeah we've got more
social distancing and it's a friendly
atmosphere
there's a quite more iceland fans of the
fight would be and uh yeah
it's great it's just like being the game
itself there are no problems no problems
as i said you have followed england for
years now over a decade going in just
about every game
you ever known a game like this uh well
there was one two years ago in croatia
uh where croatia had to play against van
closed those after
a racist incident and there was about 50
fans
up up on the hill in croatia and uh but
they're
they're the hardcore fans i know most of
them all good lads
and unfortunately the company here today
they chose not to they chose dr
quarantine and i wish
i was here with me now but apart from
that this is
a surreal game it's the second game down
closed doors and i'm just glad to be
here and hopefully coming
can win and and what about those chad
who are going to watch this and go this
is kind of nuts five days quarantining
in reykjavik on your own in a hotel room
just to watch a game of football through
a barred gate
what drives someone like you to do that
well i asked yourself the same question
when i landed in recovery i thought
what am i doing but as the days went on
it got it got a bit easier and i'm
finally here now but um yeah i must
admit to myself i always question myself
thinking chad
why are you doing this but it's worth it
now and if we could see his win today
it'll be worth it totally 100
all right give it give us your thoughts
on the game england have put out a
strong team yeah what's the result going
to be um
i'll put my neck on the line and i'll
say four kneeling one four
i'll go far near england yeah nick on
the line yes right there you go
gentlemen thank you very much
we're gonna let you enjoy uh the game
you've heard that prediction
uh uh there first four nil england the
last time these two teams met england
managed to lose 2-1
in what was and remains one of the most
humiliating defeats
the english football team has ever said
four nil i think english fans would
quite like
but frankly avoiding disaster is
probably top of the list